[Musique]
1 1 à à à
elle m'a dit oui c'est pas parce que tu
as un gros ventre que tu devais deux
heures à préparer un
[Rires]
bébé je te jure c'est comme si tu
faisais des attentes relatifs à dix ans
ferme un contrat créé des ados vie
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'ai toujours voulu l'être oui
maintenant dire que je le suis c'est un
peu présomptueux même s'il peut être que
je ne suis peut-être que je ne suis pas
je pense que c'est aux jo gens de le
dire voilà quand tu es le meilleur tu
n'as pas besoin de le dire donc j'essaie
de montrer sur le terrain ce que je sais
faire et après si les gens pensent je
suis le meilleur tant mieux sinon tant
pis y'a pas mort de mon fils vient de me
disais que votre avenir ils dépendaient
de plusieurs paramètres que votre
décision n'était pas prise quelles sont
ces paramètres qui vont décider de votre
avenir j'ai pas répondu à tes collègues
lorsque tu fera pas exception mais j'ai
déjà donné pas mal d'informations je
pense que vous avez de quoi faire là
hier
cauchemar car
c'était bien sûr
canada au
[Rires]
japon ou
bien par contre